dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir neural network
based learning algorithms are on the
rise these days and even though it is
common knowledge that they are capable
of image classification or in other
words looking at an image and saying
whether it depicts a dog or a cat
nowadays they can do much much more in
this series we covered a stunning paper
that showcased the system that could not
only classify an image but write the
proper sentence on what is going on and
could cover even highly non-trivial
cases you may be surprised but this
thing is not recent at all this is four
year old news insanity later researchers
turned this whole problem around and
performed something that was previously
thought to be impossible they started
using these networks to generate
photorealistic images from a written
text description we could create new
bird species by specifying that it
should have orange legs and a short
yellow bill later researchers at Nvidia
recognized and addressed two
shortcomings one was that the images
were not that detailed and two even
though we could input text we couldn't
exert too much artistic control over the
results in came style Gant
to the rescue which was able to perform
both of these difficult tasks really
well these images were progressively
grown which means that we started out
with a course image and go over it over
and over again adding new details this
is what the results look like and we can
marvel at the fact that none of these
people are real however some of these
images were still contaminated by
unwanted artifacts furthermore there are
some features that are highly localized
as we exert control over these images
you can see how this part of the teeth
and eyes are pinned to a particular
position and the algorithm just refuses
to let it go sometimes to the detriment
of its surroundings this new work is
titled sty again - and it addresses all
of these problems in one go
perhaps this is the only place on the
Internet where we can say that finally
teeth and eyes are now allowed to float
around freely and mean it with a
positive sentiment here you see a few
hand-picked examples from the best ones
and I have to say these are i popping
lee detailed incorrect looking images
my goodness the mixing examples you see
here are also outstanding way better
than the previous version also note that
as there are plenty of training images
out there for many other things beyond
human faces it can also generate cars
churches horses and of course cats now
that the original stag and one work has
been out for a while
we have a little more clarity and
understanding as to how it does what it
does and the redundant parts of the
architecture have been revised and
simplified this clarity comes with
additional advantages beyond faster and
higher quality training and image
generation for instance interestingly
despite the fact that the quality has
improved significantly images made with
a new method can be detected more easily
note that the paper does much much more
than this so make sure to have a look in
the video description in this series we
always say that two more papers down the
line and this technique will be leaps
and bounds beyond the first iteration
well here we are not two but only one
more people down the line what a time to
be alive the source code of this project
is also available what's more it even
runs in your browser this episode has
been supported by weights and biases
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments in your deep
learning projects it can save you a ton
of time and money in these projects and
is being used by open a Toyota Research
Stanford and Berkeley here you see a
beautiful final report on one of their
projects on classifying parts of street
images and see how these learning
algorithms evolve over time make sure to
visit them through wendy b.com slash
papers or just click the link in the
video description and you can get a free
demo today or thanks to weights and
biases for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time